[موسيقى]
البحريه الامريكيه سقوط خراك ضربه موجعه
لسلمسكي وهي اكبر خساره لكياب فهل سقطت
خركب حقا والناتو يعلن اولى خيبات امله في
اوكرانيا واول سفينه غربيه تقع في مصيده
الدب الروسي وموسكو سنترككم للمره الاخيره
وبطريقه ذكيه روسيه تخترق الاراضي
البولنديه بينما ترد وارسو بصفقه مكونه من
الف دبابه وسلاح الماني جديد يدخل خط
الحرب الاوكرانيه ومسيره بوتين في خطر
الغرب يرشح النساء لمنصب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني فهل بني الرجال في المعارك وصين
تحذر امريكا وتتوعد تايوان وبشده وكيم
يعود بقانون جديد يربك المدخنين وانقلاب
النيجر يوجه النداء للدول الغربيه
والالمان يقولون
لقد انتهي صفعه روسيه لكياف والغرب
الاجواء مهيئه والصيف يرخص دونه ليضرب
الدب الروسي ضربته القويه في اوكرانيا ولا
يبالي باي رد غربي وها هو عقيد البحريه
الامريكيه المتقاعد
يقولها صراحه بانه جوم روسيا الناجحه في
مقاطعه خراكوف بعد فشل الهجوم الاوكراني
في مقاطعه زابوريجيا يعتبر ضربه موجعه
لكياف مضيفا سيكون هذا اكبر فشل على خلفيه
الهجوم المضاد المتوقف للقوات الاوكرانيه
وذلك بحسب صحيفه فيا لها من صفعه روسيه
الموشعه حقا وقد ذكرت مصادر الاوكرانيه
المسؤوله ان القوات الاوكرانيه تقوم
باجلاء سكان من مناطق تسيطر عليها في
مقاطعه خراكوب على خلفيه تقدم القوات
الروسيه في اتجاه كوبيانسيك حيث باتت قوات
موسكو على بعد بضعه كيلومترات من مدينه
كوبيانسك فيما اعلنت الروسيه تحرير 5
بلدات اخرى في مقاطعه خراكياف في اطار
السعي لتحرير مقاطعه بالكامل فهل تسقط
حركات على طريقه بخموت لتاتي الاجابه
غربيه هذه المره حيث افادت صحيفه
في اجبار روسيا على الدخول في مفاوضات هذا
الشتاء ولكن هذا غير وارد الان فالنات وفق
صحيفه الطائف كان يامل بحدوث معجزه في
هجومهم المضاد ولكن لا يمكن شن حرب على
اساس التفاؤل ودعوني اضيف بان زمن
المعجزات قد انتهى يا ساده حتى ان الحلفاء
الغربيين صاروا يفضلون تعيين امراه على
راس وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه في حال اقاله
الوزيره الحالي
الذي تلاحقه الهزائم وتحيط به شبهات بحسب
صحيفه سترانا الاوكرانيه فهل تستطيع
النساء فعل ما لم يفعله الرجال ام ان
للغرب مارب اخرى والى ميدان المعارك في
اوكرانيا وعلى عكس ما يراه الغرب اعلنت ان
قواتها احرز الت في جنوب البلاد وانتزعت
السيطره على اراضي جديده من القوات
الروسيه دون تحديد المناطق وعلى صعيد
منفصل اعلنت هيئه اركان الجيش الاوكراني
انها حققت نجاحا جزئيا في قريه روبوتين
بمنطقه زبارود فيما قالت قياده عمليات
الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني ان قواتها
استهدفت قاعده عسكريه روسيه في راديانسك
بمقاطعه خيراسون جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا من
جانبه قال الجيش الاوكراني ان موسم
التفجيرات في القرن سيستمر حتى تحريرها
على حد وصفه لتعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها قتلت حوالي
545 جنديا الاوكرانيا على مختلف المحاور
خلال 24 ساعه كما اسقطت مروحيه اوكرانيه
في اجواء دنياك وخمسه وعشرين مسيره في
مناطق متفرقه بعضها في سماء مقاطاعتي بيل
جراد وكورساك وفي ارقام كهذه تبقى العهده
على المصدر وها نحن نتصفحه امامكم في
الموقع الرسمي الحكومه الروسيه وعلى ذكر
المسيرات كشفت صحيفه الالمانيه ان الشركه
الالمانيه للصناعات الدفاعيه غين ميتال
ستزود القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه بطائره
استطلاع بدون طيار حديثه من طراز
الخارقه بنهايه العام 2023 وذلك لمواجهه
المسيرات الروسيه والى احشاء البحار
والمحيطات حيث اطلقت سفينه تابعه للبحريه
الروسيه طلقات تحذيريه من اسلحتها نحو
سفينه شحن اجنبيه كانت متجهه الى ميناء
اسماعيل الاوكراني حتى تم اجبار السفينه
الاجنبيه على توقف لتفتيشها وكالعاده
المصدر هو من يتحدث يمكن القول بان اهم
حدث اليوم هو هذا الاجراء الذي قامت به
قوات الروسيه خاصه القوات البحريه في
البحر الاسود ايقاف سفينه تفتيش هذه
السفينه وكذلك اطلاق هذه السفينه لاكمال
مسيره ا لننتقل الان الى نتائج
حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان ثمه
ادله على ان روسيا قد تخلت عن دعم مجموعه
فاغنا واضافت ان مجموعه تتجه الى خفض عدد
عناصرها لتقليل تكاليف الاجور بسبب ازمتها
الماليه اني اشتم رائحه خطه من تحت
الطاوله فما هو الهدف هذه المره ومن
اوكرانيا الى الجاره بولندا حيث اتهم رئيس
وزراء بولندا ماتيوس مورافيتسكي روسيا
وبيلاروسيا بالتسبب في ارتفاع نسبه تدفق
المهاجرين ومحاوله عبورهم الحدود الشرقيه
بشكل غير قانوني وذلك في مقابله مع صحيفه
كوريا
الايطاليه مضيفا انها خطه مشتركه لروسيا
وبيلاروس اللتين تريدان زعزعه استقرار ليس
فقط بلدنا ولكن الاتحاد الاوروبي باكمله
يبدو ان المهاجرين من افراد فاغنر والا
لما تحدث مورفتسكي هكذا اليس كذلك برايكم
على ذات قال وزير الدفاع البولندي ماريوس
بلاش تشاك ان القوات المسلحه البولنديه
ستشتري الف دبابه من الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه بحسب وكاله
الاحداث والتطورات قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ان السبب الجذري لازمه مضيق
تايوان يكمن في محاولات الولايات المتحده
استغلال قضيه تايوان وذلك لاحتواء الصين
بينما توعدت باتخاذ اجراءات حازمه وقويه
ردا على زيارت نائب رئيس تايوان الى
الولايات المتحده وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه
انها تعارض اي تواصل رسمي بين واشنطن
وتايوان في كوريا الشماليه السجن لمن يلف
السجائر بصوره كام وتوجيهات صارمه
للكوريين الشماليين بحمايه صور وتماثيل
الزعيم وعائلته في المنازل والشوارع اثناء
العاصفه خانار دعا علي الامين الزين رئيس
الحكومه الجديده المعين من قبل المجلس
العسكري الى رفع العقوبات غير الانسانيه
وغير العادله التي فرضتها المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اي ايكوس على
النيجر
طلب وفد من المجموعه العسكريه الانقلابيه
في النيجر من سلطات غينيا تعزيز الدعم
لمواجهه التحديات المقبله فيما تلوح دول
غرب افريقيا بالتدخل عسكريا لاعاده النظام
الدستوري الى ميامي اظهر استطلاع للرائي
ان غالبيه الالمان يعتبرون ان المستشار
الالماني زعما ضعيفا ولا يمكنه تسيير
قضايا البلاد السياسيه كما يجب وذلك وفق
استطلاع اجرت شركه الابحاث بتكليف من قناه
الالمانيه
[موسيقى]